Here’s the timeline of the history of Genetics.
Beginning with the work of Gregor Mendel,
we have reached this point: the experiment
which proved that it is DNA which is the genetic
material.
Clearly, the next step would be to understand
the structure of DNA.
So how is this biomolecule structured?
What are its constituent molecules?
Let us find that out in this video!
The structure of the DNA molecule was discovered
in the early years of 1950s.
Note that the STRUCTURE was discovered, not
the molecule!
The discovery of DNA molecule predates to
the 18th century.
But DNA was ignored for a long time and it
was “PROTIENS” that grabbed a lot of attention.
However, post Griffith’s transformation
experiment, the other two notable works in
the timeline helped shift the focus towards DNA.
So around the early years of 1950s, an English
chemist named Rosalind Franklin, started working
on DNA molecules.
She isolated the DNA crystals and shone X-rays
on them.
As a result, she obtained fine images of the
structure of DNA molecules.
According to sources, the best one looked
somewhat like this!
Around the same time, Francis Crick and James
Watson, two scientists in the field of genetics,
worked on the structure of DNA and reached
a similar conclusion like Franklin did!
However, according to sources, they were fortunate
to receive better and earlier recognition
compared to Franklin.
They even shared a Nobel Prize with Maurice
Wilkins for their discovery of the double
helical structure of DNA.
Let us understand how exactly this double
helical structure looks!
We may have come across this structure of
DNA somewhere.
Is this how it really looks?
Yes!
According to Franklin, Watson and Crick, the
DNA is made up of three major components.
One is a pentose sugar molecule called Deoxyribose!
How is this obtained?
It is obtained by removing one oxygen atom
from a ribose molecule.
Thus the name “Deoxyribonucleic acid”.
The second component is a phosphate group.
This helps bind the two deoxyribose molecules
together!
The third and fifth carbon atoms of the adjacent
deoxyribose molecules are bound by the Phosphate
groups!
Lastly, the nitrogenous bases form the core
of the double helix!
These are four different molecules that bind
in pairs.
Two of them are called purines and the other
two are called pyrimidines.
Adenine and Guanine are the two purines which
bond with the pyrimidines thymine and cytosine.
And can any purine bind with any pyrimidine?
Nope!
It is a thumb rule that Adenine always binds
with Thymine; while Guanine binds with cytosine
only!
These molecules are bound to each other with
the help of Hydrogen bonds.
Adenine binds with thymine with the help of
2 hydrogen bonds.
Guanine and cytosine however, bind with three
hydrogen bonds.
Did you know that one unit consisting of a
deoxyribose molecule, one nitrogenous base
and a phosphate group is called a “Nucleotide”?
And what if the phosphate group is removed
from this nucleotide unit?
It is called a “Nucleoside” then!
Nora wants to know if there is any way of
measuring a DNA molecule?
What about its dimensions?
Watch the next part to know more!
The dimensions of DNA are very simple and
easy to remember!
The diameter of the double helix is around
2 nanometres.
The double helical strand has one major and
one minor groove that makes up one turn.
The length of one turn is around 3.4 nanometres.
And there are around 10 base pairs in one turn.
Now can you help me with the distance between
the two adjacent base-pairs?
It’s simple!
The distance is zero point three four nanometres!
It is simply 3.4 divided by 10!!
This is how the molecules are arranged!
So in this double helix, this portion is the
backbone which is made up of the Deoxyribose
molecules and the phosphate groups.
Where as, this portion that forms the core,
is made up of the nitrogenous bases.
Now can you guess the chemical nature of DNA?
Since it contains nitrogenous “BASES”,
you would say that DNA is basic in nature,
right?
But that is not true!
DNA is in fact, acidic in nature!
The presence of phosphate groups makes the
molecule acidic in nature!
What about its physical appearance?
Can you tell me how LONG can this double helix be?
Let me tell you an interesting fact!
If all the DNA from a single cell is pulled
out and stretched, then it would touch approximately
2 metres in length!
Yes!
It’s that long!
But if the DNA stretch is so long, then how
does it fit into such a tiny nucleus?
We know that a cell is extremely tiny, and
the nucleus occupies a VERY small portion
of the tiny cell!
So how does such a long stretch of DNA fit
into such a tiny space?
The answer is quite simple!
How do we fit a long telephone wire in a small
space?
Yes: using the process of COILING!
Similarly, “Coiling” the DNA helps reduce
its volume and fits it into the tiny nucleus!
But what does it coil around?
Is there any support for this structure?
Or does the long stretch coil around itself?
Well, there are highly specialised proteins
that help us in this!
These are called the Histone proteins!
A total of five Histone proteins help in the
wrapping of the DNA molecule!
Histone proteins namely H-1, H-2A, H-2B, H3
and H4 serve this purpose!
Among these, the H-2A, H-2B, H3 and H4 come
in doubles to form a ball like structure which
looks somewhat like this!
The stretch of DNA then easily wraps around
this octamer formed!
And what function does the H-1 serve?
Basically the H-1 protein helps in attaching
the DNA to the octamer and keeping it intact
on place.
In other words, it helps to hold the complete structure!
This unit of the DNA string wrapped on the
histone core is called “Nucleosome”.
Does this structure resemble something?
Yes!
It looks like a bead having a string wound around it!
That is the reason why the nucleosomes are
referred to as the “Beads on a string”
structures!
Any idea what kind of a structure is obtained
from this?
This kind of coiling forms the basic unit
for the formation of the chromatin structure!
Yes!
We know that chromatin, and thus the chromosomes,
are made up of DNA.
So it is this pattern of arrangement of the
DNA that forms coils and helps in the formation
of the chromatin structure!